are you wearing that shirt because your
Panther oh no I could though miss got
this got so sad what yeah we're gonna
know what yeah we're on we're on boom
hey listen listenmi you when do it what
you went and did it yeah you went and
did the older can right now I haven't
seen the wings I can just see its nose I
can see see it's [ __ ] nose I need you
say you didn't get the diaper like I
told you you had to go and get the
[ __ ] pound terrified of snakes I'm
allergic to cats so pick your poison and
you decided just to get out Panther well
this this represents I beat Corona been
tested twice now it does look super so
makes those wings are too small to even
get that [ __ ] Panther off the ground
so now it's kind of annoying shitty
wings clear out like Joe's you've seen a
flying Panther no I haven't then how the
[ __ ] would you know because this is how
I vision my aerodynamic lady doesn't
make any sense there's no way a mini
Panther well mini head
stop doing that
no and by the way I Got News for You
looks more like a [ __ ] mountain lion
no way well this this artwork is so dope
Panthers I'm so old it doesn't matter
but that has wings coming out of it it's
like Gil I know and why did you choose
to have a panther with wings you know
why I'm just saying I ride my mountain
bike and that's I picture myself on that
bike as the thing the president of the
thick boys bike club I'm going down the
mountain I picture myself as a panther
with wings a panther and I'd [ __ ] go
hard dude uh-huh do you want in the club
I don't you can't I'm skinny oh hold on
it's not like I want to be clubbed so
you're keeping me out of the club
because I'm not [ __ ] thick enough
start eating dude
no because you know what my body type
doesn't call for thickness I'm thin man
I'll start my own company called thin
man take for it thin boy yeah it just
doesn't justice I'm saying
Roth didn't Boy hey who wants to be part
of the thin boy club let me say will
rumble will Rumble with you thick boys
oh good luck with that dude
yeah you guys applied beat us but we're
quick and we're fast and we get
underneath chinnamma City a picture for
my boy chin happy birthday
Thank You Bryan 42 43 literally 43 today
10 years 43 man wish you I wish you the
10 years I've had no wow somehow you've
obviously most of it for sure the
majority of it
I've had a good life we've known you for
what seven eight years now no about four
years almost of four years a little over
four years right I think it's close to
four years Karimi spoken I think you
know I sent you a picture chin from my
guy Daniel Silva when I say when I put
out that thick boy email or I'm sorry
Instagram post saying hey I need a
tattoo artists anybody down and so many
sheep or like no one's getting these
Crona times good luck loser when I say I
had every tattoo artist reach out yeah
name one they all reached out yeah this
dude Daniel Silva was like yo I'm in the
Hills because you can get give him a
tattoo and be covert say what's one on
one he's even tested I've been telling
you wear a mask then we don't wear masks
around jet inclusive but no I do yeah
but he's been tested I've been tested so
what's doing you do it there's nobody
else there that's his crib in the
Hollywood Hills by the way oh he's not
he's not doing well for himself
he's doing well oh he's not 25 when the
top tattoo artists in the world he five
got he a hooker to the kids on looker
you should feel is an Instagram page
he's a dime a dime yeah he's a super
dope looking fella and an artist and
they're not one of the best artists have
twos all these celebrities did he say
alright I'll do a Panther if you're on
he's like dude this is sick and he's
young heals let's run it I was like
[ __ ] let's run yeah he went let's run
this [ __ ] I want to say let me tell it
[ __ ] you let's run it dude let's run it
and I text him back i text enough that
don't dude thanks for running it when
he's five years old 25 one the top
tattoo artists in the nation in the
world
was in San Francisco's like you know
what he was killing up there's like any
more of a challenge came to LA bought a
house in the hills in the McLaren there
you go he's doing very well kids killing
it
yeah he's an artist Daniel Silva Silva
what ethnicity I would say he's got to
be Brazilian his Papa's Brazilian
there's where he gets her looks he said
did you make the argument that
Brazilians on average of the
best-looking people in the world know
the guys look like [ __ ]
I don't think so the guys look like [ __ ]
guys a good way Dulli name one just up
to here Gracie who was younger Kron
Gracie who's young I mean these are
good-looking people um a lot of guys
that are good-looking a lot of a lot of
good-looking that they're pretty good
looking yeah Luke Rockhold I mean a lot
of now but um there are a lot of
parallel cut off America in general yeah
Columbia Columbia my mate Brazil I'd say
the women are the best-looking the guys
I don't know I feel like the guys are in
Dagestan have something to say what do
you mean
well cuz they're hideous hideous they
just yeah I but you see ya there don't
know a man maybe Dagestan iam model is
right right they're just not smart urges
yeah and it just big kind of thick well
they were toughest and go to the
toughest in the world yeah you don't be
good to be the toughest in the world and
the best right you gotta leave it out
they look a little medieval yeah got
like I never saw Harry yeah and I just
wouldn't thick thick if you've seen a
skinny no whoa who's that guy we have
the Sun [ __ ] I mean commit come eat
the beats a beats and beats a beat like
this is he another artist register guys
order that's Nyjah Huston who we've had
on the pocket kid before our own best
that I know when we interviewed him he's
tiny
that's crazy how tall is this Silva kid
uh six one maybe okay star god damn he's
he's sexy right he is fine as [ __ ] I
know
hmm I know well and tall to he'll give
the pictures when he's like in Europe
and [ __ ] he just no game well leave this
your model bro
he's obviously he looks like a model to
me but it's a beautiful man
proud of them and he knows how to put it
together he knows he knows he's cuz he's
an artist so he knows yes he's got an
eye for proportion and color and
everything I mean you're not gonna well
just the I knew I wasn't good here and
he's rich
yes and I just knew I was in good hands
with the details because I brought him
something that like I drew and his my
idea and he's like dude he can't cuz the
flow and he's like going over details
like and you can't put it there you have
to put it here Wow by the way so let me
ask you this go back to the go back to
the couple up there so that that tiger
is that what he's drawing freehand was
he doing that for him really he draws it
on his computer print it out puts the
ink on your skin and then goes huh it's
like a like the outline on your skin
anything goes and his signature is the
colored eyes now I got chin for his
birthday he's you know tattoo on his
neck right how do you get that color on
the skin you'll be pretty white to get
that like my skin would it take to that
Wow yeah I guess I can get a tattoo now
and get those those blue eyes I've
always wanted yeah be cool oh my god she
had Tiger blue eyes whatever um but chin
for his birthday 43rd he's always
wanting to neck that - so your boy
hooked him up he's going tonight at six
o'clock well whenever I'm done with this
you getting your neck tight you bought
him a neck tattoo
thank you breelyn what are you gonna get
on your neck it's either gonna be a fish
or a moon okay now hold on hold on Bryan
I know you're older so I know this isn't
cool to you I just think that in general
I okay I'm gonna be nice be nice because
remember he's a fisherman I do love this
kind of fish you know what's in it
Chin's heart grouper fish it's too fat
okay so you want attentions bones trout
trout but it doesn't look that great on
tattoo no no it just looks like a fish
doesn't it checks out the roster point
you know what my idea was for him what
can I do no that'd be cool I like where
your head's at yeah Siamese fighting
fish now that I understand why cuz it's
specific huh it's a fighter
every badass looking they're very
aggressive and there are little fins
haven't going yeah okay but see now
that's a Beautif
tattoo now that let's do detailed look
at look at the blue one though there's a
bunch this one look at that blue one
that's too much on chintz neck dude
probably like a neat simple on it and
not color but I like as I'm easy
that's it so that I like I I don't feel
like there's any other option but a
Siamese fighting fish ready almost run
another one by you okay you know who the
the most underrated fishes of all time
hold on now if you had a fish tank as a
kid you'd know this hold on hold on hold
on I might know I referred him as a
janitor because he cleans things up in
the tank and he looks very friendly okay
he might be a Blowfish or he might be a
selfish
I said sucker fish sucker fish might be
a sucker fish these bad boys sacré fish
but yeah that's it going that's sick
I like the one with the little top hat
dad to me I like go with humor so I like
humor I like the one with the top hat on
that's really cute
although on your neck it might be a
problem the jet the Siamese fight you
could not get a tattoo on your neck
because you're 43 but I'm us and commit
to that then go with a Siamese fighting
fish what color are you gonna choose
black have to be black really I'm
rethinking the tattoo now because I
thought I was gonna be with that crazy
awesome hardest but now that other guys
other guys I heard he's good - he's
really legit yeah you're not gonna be
with the dimepiece that's what I was
thinking but no he's not the guy in
Santa Monica the dime piece just so yet
dime piece 2000 hours
booked out for two years only was that
Yelling's cuz the other cancellation Wow
Jesus yeah chin I'm gonna see vans work
before how you being down your what did
you not look at the guy say you yeah I
saw this on some Instagram posts so
you're not feeling it chin also your
tattoo Brian could do it a lot of people
could you're Brian could do it you don't
need [ __ ] Miami to do let's not get a
moon no no it's a little depressing be
sick it's like a crescent but then it's
it's like with fish details that's what
I'm thinking right now safe no I didn't
even give me so small though it's me
gonna know that I actually did a my my
girlfriend did a thing here it's gonna
be like probably like that baby oh oh
oh we going okay if I'm gonna get on
mine okay Birdman is that ready yeah
yeah a third man test money
thanks Sally this is our first bonus
episode [ __ ] yeah nothing so far so good
we're crushing it can't wait til [ __ ]
Will Sasso face times in mm-hmm now let
me ask you this chin huh
what is it gonna be Siamese fighting
fish no Siamese Japanese let's do to do
joking oh really
yeah he can't yellows neck detail so
then so then maybe moon yeah I'm gonna
see this guy can actually do what I let
me see that would you say chin let me
see if you can do what I imagine cuz I
do imagine some some different details I
think like what so I'll be like a moon
but then there's gonna be a lot of
little you know like fish skills on it
not even skill it's just like kind of
cool little shapes and stuff and then
little little parts of like fish look
the eyes maybe a couple things here and
there sure sure ya know it's gonna be
tough I know it why don't you just have
to be so big for that detail it'll be
bigger come on that's how you spoke it
yeah that's dope is that Tinkerbell it
looks like Sailor Moon how about that
size though not too much I thought I was
thinking smaller but your tattoo brother
here it's on your neck so I also don't
believe in running your tattoo by your
friends or family really now that's a
suede the suede suede me big doing yeah
then you overthink everything and then
you know yeah but also the tattoo is on
your body so it should be what you want
not what anyone else wants my body my
business yeah yeah necklace that girl
has on her chest that that sort of those
dots that's really subtle and cool those
morals right and it was really cool dude
okay right now if girl has a chest
tattoo she do an anal yep
that's fine it's yeah yeah there you go
so if a girl has tattoos all over her
neck up to her chin should deep you're
like I'd like to have sex with her once
once you know I mean because sometimes
you like ooh
there might be something I see a guy
like that I sure he's a nice person but
I also I have an inherent prejudice
where I go who he may not be too stable
Yeah right yeah usually big it's a big
big commitment but I see a girl I'm
thinking I get horny hang on yeah hang
on
so moon fish is there any other is there
a third it's just run through the ideas
is there any writing you could do if
there is there is there all about
musical notes Oh what about a guitar
music something about music why wouldn't
you do something that is what you are
like music dude I've seen too many of
those tattoos it looks to me I'm sure
they look what about what about what is
what is your favorite what is your
favorite chord a flat yeah is that the
right word chord I mean yeah we don't
get that on you what's your favorite
verse your musical verse that kind of
moves you what's it what's the most
unique like you know it's like when I
hear Zeppelin like Ganon and then oh
yeah a unique yeah it does the tattoo
well that was a musician what'd you do
bro what would be what would be the
unique inspiration a moon with fish
tails on it he's first effort I don't
want like a music no different that's
just way different
that's pretty gentle so random also Led
Zeppelin notes on your neck that's not
very original not not let Zeppelin notes
but whatever whatever music moves you
inspire hey cover your whole [ __ ]
nice little sheet me what we're talking
about these hit the showers
no because I believe if you're gonna
write something it's gotta be specific
and meaningful no it doesn't though chin
it shouldn't be a problem right it's the
bra this problem with older man a
panther with wing they put too much
value it like it's too much of a big
deal tell me on your neck forever it's
on your neck yeah he can hide that with
his sleeves which he's already doing cuz
he he's self-conscious of his tattoos
well just why'd you stand up hey be
quiet you have a hoodie on you're 57 so
what it's comfortable
hey chin you want the best piece of
advice I can give your don't listen
abroad especially when it comes to
tattoos and business all right well well
hey you should have gotten a tattoo by
now Brian you know I mean least Jim
Carrey says what he's gonna do you know
I understand I just if you guys can give
me a tattoo that's good I'll get it get
a fish in the shape of a moon Micra said
that oh so maybe you can shape of a moon
that's you yeah
in the shape of a moon that's what I'm
doing oh that's not thinking of that
might be alright let me see it I like a
moon covered in fish scales also known
as capatch uh you know these when fish
turn it kind of looks like a moon like a
c-shape I mean I guess that's a cute
little thing over there
I don't think Chin's going for cute
specially on your neck what did your
girl think of a channel she in now she
didn't like it she didn't like it no god
damn it
well I mean Kat do well uh yeah well
think deeply about this don't overthink
it though no I do want I do want to I've
been wanting one for a long time did you
tried getting on it when we're in Dublin
I wanted to use this on my neck in
Dublin bro just get a [ __ ] get a
ti-83 calculator now get the
testosterone molecule on your neck why
don't you get a [ __ ] and some guys have
that problem I'm spitballing some guys
actually have that problem what's that
yeah it's all shaped up know where that
is that's just the way they're going oh
look at the testosterone molecule that's
nice that's a real nice Oh chin get
self-made on your neck self-made man no
vertices of testosterone a lot of wild
got to you go man there are [ __ ] kids
these days though they're even you know
I might be a little outlandish tattoos
kids get the face and that tattoos like
that's their first ones now it's just a
thing where society you know it's just a
thing you're gonna get CEOs with face
tattoos part of part of being older is
that you see as people get older and
they were radical and crazy when they
were younger boy it becomes a difficult
thing to kind of manage now yeah yeah
I'm gonna try you I'm gonna try your
ribs chin go for it
can I get a piece of that meat on
[ __ ] get a pair of tongs like Korean
barbecue tongs I'll tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue okay what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]